nous allons dans un instant parler de
sport comme chaque lundi dans ce set 8
anthony rech va me rejoindre paravent
nous faisons le point sur cette
mobilisation d'une partie des salariés
de la poste c'est notre fait du jour là
nous faisons le point sur l'actualité du
jour l'actualité de ce 15 octobre et
donc avec la colère d'une partie des
salariés et des syndicats de la poste
dans les yvelines à elancourt maurepas
trappe magny les hameaux et montigny le
bretonneux l'heure était à la grève un
rassemblement a eu lieu devant le siège
de l'entreprise à saint quentin en
yvelines explications de johanna soudry
et de guillaume campe ce manque de
communication absence de dialogue social
mépris face aux salariés telles sont les
revendications de la cgt de la poste
seraient concernées les sites de
courriers de montigny elancourt maurepas
trappe et magny les hameaux
lundi matin une dizaine d'employés s'est
réunie devant le bureau de saint quentin
en yvelines
on est peu nombreux présents là ce matin
apparemment par contre il y aurait un
taux de grévistes assez important mais
bon les camarades ont eu énormément de
pression et ont eu peur de se déplacer
le problème qui se pose sur cette
réorganisation la met sur toutes les
autres dans le département et au niveau
national c'est la même chose on reproche
en fait à la poste de redémarrer ses
réorganisations sans prendre part à ce
que la commission caspar qui est une
commission qui a eu pour but de mettre
en évidence certaines choses qui se
passent pas bien on voudrait nous que ce
soit bien remis sur la table et qu'on
reprenne les charges de travail reprend
l'humain pour illustrer les
dysfonctionnements qu'ils évoquent les
syndicats pointent du doigt la
réorganisation du bureau de poste de
magny les hameaux
le bureau de magny les hameaux va être
délocalisée sur saint rémy les chevreuse
les collègues qui travaillent sur
manille vont être donc rattaché au
bureau de saint rémy et auront pour
aller travailler sur leur tournée de
manille environ 15 minutes de trajet
supplémentaire pour aller sur leur
tournée et 15 minutes pour revenir à peu
près ça c'est pas intégré dans leur
temps de travail
le bureau d'elancourt lieu aussi
connaîtra quelques changements puisqu'il
sera relocalisée sur mon repas le bureau
d'elancourt doit aussi le 20 novembre
comme manny être délocalisés
sur mon repas il faut savoir que les
facteurs à l'origine il ya huit ans
était déjà sur leurs pas et qu'on les a
déplacés à elancourt aujourd'hui huit
ans après on les ramène sur mon repas
avec un site qui n'est pas conforme
ils ont fait des travaux certes dedans
mais il est apparu des fissures sur les
murs des choses comme ça c'est un site
qui est trop petit pour accueillir tout
le monde pour travailler dans des
conditions décentes la poste que nous
avons contactés a répondu aux différents
points évoqués
le déménagement du bureau de magny les
hameaux permet un rapatriement vers une
plate forme récente mieux adapté aux
exigences de production du côté de
maurepas le site a subi des travaux de
réaménagement il ya tout juste un an il
répond donc aux normes actuelles quant
au manque de communication dénoncé par
la cgt la poste des yvelines explique
que des plénières avec les agents et les
organisations syndicales sont
régulièrement organisés et comme insiste
la direction l'écoutent individuel est
une option possible